in realtà oltre occuparmi public policy
in google sono prima di tutto un allievo
di una scuola di un pezzetto pedagogico
e culturale della linea di montessori un
po meno famoso che è quella di
pronunciare uno degli ultimi allievi di
quel tipo di scuola lì e poi ho avuto la
fortuna per un po di tempo è la mia vita
e fare pure la stessa della distruzione
del mio comune e la passione per
l'educazione delle nozze l'educazione
alla porta che non mi levo indosso e che
mi porto dietro anche adesso in google
non mi voglio raccontare la mia storia
in realtà vi voglio raccontare la storia
di antonella a tre la ragazza che ha 23
anni meno di me e non arriva a 30 è una
ragazza che forse paradigmatico per
questo paese nel senso che ha come molti
della sua generazione studiato
all'estero parla perfettamente inglese
ha studiato a lisbona ho studiato a
dublino in maniera differente dagli
altri
a un certo punto si metteva pure i
cartelli al collo perché aveva deciso
che voleva stare in italia cioè una di
quelle che se ne era andata per studiare
e appassionata di questo paese voleva
restare in italia a lavorare
scriveva sul suo blog ormai un anno e
mezzo fa che da lì a poco invece si
sarebbe arresa all'evidenza e avrebbe
fatto la scelta di trasferirsi
definitivamente all'estero perché i
soldi non bastavano la precarietà del
lavoro non le permetteva andare avanti
antonella è una persona che aveva
studiato nella sua internazionale
sviluppo locale o per dirla con una
battuta realtà sviluppo locale l'ho
studiato pure io però un po quelle
università che quanto dice in giro che
lei studiava della fabbrica della
disoccupazione
e invece noi pensiamo che proprio da
quelli che hanno passione per questo
paese per il suo sviluppo possa passare
un pezzo del futuro dell'italia prima si
parlava tanto nello studiare quello per
cui si appassioni non quello che ci
raccontano serve ecco chi voleva
raccontare sosterà per questo perché in
realtà siamo riusciti a trattenere
antonella
lei ha vinto una borsa di studio che
abbiamo bambino appunto un anno e mezzo
fa e per le sue stesse parole sorprese
tutte dal suo blog quindi poi vede
potete leggere si è ritrovato a fare
questo lavoro impressionante di lavorare
con gli artigiani fiorentini per
accompagnarli nelle colonia di internet
cioè ancora sue parole si ritrovava il
maestro iconico della firenze che fa con
le mani che la chiamava nel cuore della
notte perché le cose aspettare come
utilizzare gli strumenti web per
trasmettere quel tipo di tradizione e
facendo questo lavoro ha incontrato un
po di altre storie straordinarie che
voglio condividere con voi e da questo
palco
la prima è quella di tempo forse lo
conoscete lui è molto famoso è uno dei
gioiellieri più famosi del centro
storico di firenze e il modello di
business come si dice nelle business
school di un gioielliere famoso di
centro di firenze è fondamentalmente
attrarre i turisti grazie alla vetrina
che è un di fronte star di entrare
dentro mostrarli quanto belle sono le
sue creazioni e venderle il competitor e
il vicino di vetrina
poi però grazie antonella penco si
convince a creare una presenza web e per
una di quelle strane ragioni tecniche
che stanno dentro l'utilizzo delle
piattaforme lo strumento che lui decide
di utilizzare gli impone di dare un nome
ai suoi gioielli tenco non davano messo
gioielli perché il gioielliere delle
strade fiorentine fi gioielli li mette
in vetrina e aspetta che qualcuno dica
voglio quello
internet di voi di chiamarli per nome è
noto uno stranissimo fenomeno che i
turisti in essa entra direttamente nel
suo negozio ea chiamare i suoi è lì per
nome cioè lui non ha mai venduto niente
online magari inizierà però attraverso
la rete intercettava un pezzo di gente
che magari sarebbe andata da quello del
negozio vicino ma poi ci raccontava
probabilmente per cercare anche un pezzo
di
quando canta veder firenze per il
campanile per il duomo per gli uffizi e
che nemmeno lo sapeva che a firenze si
fanno si fa anche arte orafa la seconda
storia su cui antonella ha dato una mano
è questa the florentine touch che ancora
più commovente quello presente primo
incontro in cui presentiamo la sua borsa
di studio
l'artigiano che ho sempre fatto cornici
dice che chiude non ce la fa più lui sta
tavarnelle val di pesa che è nel cuore
del chianti e faceva cornice a mano
quindi chiaramente con
l'industrializzazione della
standardizzazione un mercato difficile a
sostenere oggi grazie all'aiuto di
antonella dei ragazzi che lavorano con
lei fa stampi per pasta in legno
personalizzati e gli vende su s cos'è
che ci racconta nostre due storie e
quello di antonella in particolare ci
raccontano secondo me prima di tutto una
cosa che c'erano opportunità alla fuori
che esiste ora è che non esisteva
nemmeno solo 45 anni fa che l'economia
di internet è una roba per tutti cioè
fino a pochissimo tempo fa le aziende
come la mia faceva l'economia di
internet le aziende come quelle che
stanno qua fanno l'economia di internet
ma era una roba di chi scriveva software
a un certo punto con l'avvento delle
piattaforme delle grandi piattaforme ma
anche delle piccole come alcune di
quelle incubate qua di fatto quello che
chiamano made in italy accesso
all'economia di internet cioè per penco
o per florentin touch non serve sapere
nemmeno comprendere troppo lo strumento
perché ci sono degli alleati dei partner
che con lui aiutano a cogliere il
mercato globale
la seconda opportunità e che il mercato
esiste già
cioè noi forse ce ne andiamo troppo poco
conto però ci si è messo a indagare sui
danni del motore di ricerca ci siamo
rese conto che il made in italy è
letteralmente in buffon line cioè su
google
crescono negli ultimi anni del 22 per
cento le ricerche per parole chiave
legate
made in italy per il sud forse per
effetto anche dell'expo sono cresciute
del 33 per cento quindi con due cose è
facile tecnologicamente perché c'è un
sacco di piattaforme di start up che
aiutano i nostri artigiani astana online
il mercato esiste già ma non si usa
siamo uno degli ultimi paesi al mondo
per l'utilizzo del web ha iniziato a
studiare sul perché e ci siamo resi
conto che il 40 per cento degli
imprenditori questo paese non ha mai
messo i suoi prodotti su internet perché
ritiene che internet non gli serva
perché per esempio ritengono che i loro
clienti se in quelli che passano nel
centro storico di firenze è l'unica
sfida sia portarli dentro o perché
pensano che quel prodotto sia così
straordinario da poter essere conosciuto
solo localmente allora se il tema è un
blocco culturale quelle come antonella
sono lo strumento per rimuoverlo perché
alla fine c'è da prendere le imprese per
mano a proporre cultura ed educazione è
letteralmente educare gli imprenditori
del made in italy su come internet può
essere uno strumento per loro per
crescere antonella non era sola in
realtà antonella oggi alla coordinatrice
di 132 ragazze che hanno vinto una borsa
di studio come la sua e che sono
ospitati a 64 camere di commercio
lei era nel primo gruppo che erano un
centinaio il tuo abbiamo bandito queste
borse di studio con un'idea forte che
poi si è rivelata vincente
se noi abbiamo due problemi in questo
paese
da un lato l'ampiamente citato tema
della disoccupazione giovanile è stato
uno dei temi caldi della discussione di
stamattina e dall'altro la fatica del
nostro sistema manifatturiero
imprenditoriale di cogliere le
opportunità del web
l'italia sta al venticinquesimo posto su
28 paesi nella classifica europea di
digitalizzazione del sistema economico
probabilmente questi due problemi messi
insieme possono rappresentare un pezzo
della soluzione
e allora abbiamo pensato che un modo per
far ripartire la crescita in questo
paese fosse
dare una missione ai ragazzi e alle
ragazze italiane e chiedere loro di
essere i digitalizzatori dell'economia
italiana è una visione un po da far
tremare i polsi ma per parlare in
termini di educazione significa che
quell anello mancante tra sistema
dell'istruzione e mondo della produzione
lo si può creare se si supera
l'approccio per cui ci sono delle
persone che escono ancestrali
all'istruzione e deve andare in azienda
per imparare qualcosa e se assume il
coraggio di riconoscere che forse quelle
persone che hanno anche qualcosa da
insegnare e quindi si passa da una
logica educativa della trasmissione
della conoscenza a la logica in cui come
si diceva stamattina si tolgono i tavoli
e dentro l'impresa si fa scambio di
conoscenza trasmissione della cultura e
arricchimento complessivo del sistema
imprenditoriale
ce lo dice il mercato del lavoro perché
i 100 ragazzi di cui faceva parte
antonella oggi per la 84 per cento
lavorano cioè noi abbiamo disegnato
quelle borse di studio
noi di google insieme a unioncamere con
l'idea di aiutare le imprese
ok per noi era una politica per
rafforzare la cavallina digitalizzazione
delle imprese ci siamo resi conto che lì
assumevano cioè ci siamo resi conto che
una politica nata per insegnare qualcosa
agli imprenditori diventava un modo per
creare lavoro per dei giovani abbiamo
raccontato questa storia al ministro
poletti e è diventata una politica
pubblica una politica per spingere la
diffusione delle competenze digitale in
tutto il sistema produttivo io sono un
grande fan del piano per la sua digitale
della buona scuola
quello è un pezzo del lavoro ma noi
abbiamo oggi calcoli della commissione
europea che ci dicono che tra cinque
anni il 90 per cento di tutti i
lavoratori avrà bisogno di competenze
digitali e quindi la scuola non ci vanno
quindi abbiamo bisogno anche di
inventarci qualcosa per insegnare a come
utilizzare il web
il digitale anche a quelli che oggi
lavorano perché sennò rischiamo di
risolvere un problema è diversa e aprire
tra pochissimo tempo un altro come si fa
abbiamo creato un percorso formativo
interamente online di 50 ore sugli
strumenti internet per aiutare le
piccole e medie imprese che abbiamo dato
gratuitamente a tutti i ragazzi iscritti
al programma garanzia giovane del
ministero del lavoro e abbiamo detto
loro studiate perché tutti voi avrete
bisogno di un po di competenza digitale
quando quando andrete a lavorare poi
abbiamo anche detto mi ha detto il
ministero del lavoro che per tremila di
loro c'era un tirocinio a disposizione
pagato e quindi avevamo l'opportunità di
stare per sei mesi dentro un azienda a
imparare come funziona un azienda ma
anche a insegnare all'imprenditore come
internet può essere un alleato per
quell'impresa
guardate qui siamo in un luogo di
altissima tecnologia
ma il 18 per cento degli alberghi di
genere di genova non è provabile su
google maps 18 per cento degli alberghi
di genova cioè superare il gap di
competenze digitali spesso è avere in
azienda una persona che gli spiega che
ci si mette 8 secondi a inserire il
proprio indirizzo corretto e non costa
niente
dall'altro lato abbiamo detto agli
imprenditori
se avete un blocco culturale cioè se
pensate che internet non vi serva
fidatevi e prendetevi gratis una persona
che prova accompagnarvi a scoprire come
internet può servire a creare questo
tipo di contaminazione
in realtà i risultati sono
impressionanti quindi io sono anche un
po per chiedere una mano perché in due
mesi si sono iscritti 35.000 ragazzi
hanno già completato il corso in oltre
2000 e ci sono
oltre 1400 tirocini offerti dalle
imprese con in alcune realtà come quella
in cui siamo oggi ancora più
impressionante perché in veneto circa un
rapporto di uno a dieci tra i ragazzi
che hanno finito il corso e tirocinio
offerte dalle aziende con il problema
che il numero maggiore sono i posti di
lavoro offerti
cioè siamo nella situazione incredibile
in cui il messaggio è passato alle
imprese e ci si rende conto che forse
questa figura davvero può aiutare a
essere più competitivi nel mercato
globale io credo che questa storia sia
chiaramente la storia di un progetto
piccolo e pilota che è appena partito ma
si sa più di tutto la storia di come
nell'epoca che stiamo vivendo che un
epoca di straordinario e rapidissimo
cambiamento tecnologico quello che è
crollato e la gerarchia stessa della
formazione cioè in un momento in cui ciò
che abbiamo imparato tre anni fa diventa
obsoleto
la sfida più forte che dobbiamo avere
avere meno strumenti di trasmissione
della conoscenza è sempre più luoghi e
strumenti in cui la conoscenza se
condivide e la si crea grazie